Russia now has the third most confirmed
coronavirus cases in the world and there
are signs that the official numbers
actually underestimate the pandemics
crushing impact in that country
Elizabeth Palmer reports now on rigid
new rules in Russia's capital with
coronavirus hammering Moscow ambulances
lined up for hours outside hospitals to
deliver patients and the city government
imposed one of the strictest lockdowns
anywhere enforced by big brother
technology that's made a smart phone key
to getting out writer and journalist
McHale Fishman was in the countryside
but needed to get back to Moscow not to
get back home the special to get the
pass he had to enter personal details on
a government website where I'm coming
from
and what I'm going to eventually he
downloaded a barcode on his phone that
let him hit the road anyone traveling
more than a hundred yards from home in
Moscow needs one police run spot checks
on the streets even subway turnstiles
won't open unless the rider has already
logged the trip and on the roads cameras
and checkpoints track drivers to make
sure they're sticking to the route they
filed
fishman did make it home and he
understands extreme times call for
extreme measures but Big Brother really
is pretty much keeping tabs on you
why did Russia go that route because
Russia is a very political regime what
we actually see is lack of trust between
the government and the citizens so it's
very hard to the gun simply to ask to do
something from the people because people
would not obey because they do not trust
their government once life returns to
Moscow the government says it's gonna
delete all the data it's collected but
it is not going to forget what it's now
learned about technology and social
control for CBS this morning I'm
Elizabeth Palmer in London